[Music]
we're getting close to the end of the
year now um and you're going to talk to
us about your favorite books of 20123 so
um to start us off what what what what
actually were they well um there have
been a few and but I should start with a
disclaimer because I think some people
I'm often surprised by the number of
people who think that a litery editor's
job is to read all the new books that
come out each year and actually my job
was to subcontract that so the new books
I've read are often quite kind of random
selection rather than a kind of absolute
panoptic overview of what's come out
this year but um recently as I think I
said in our books of the year featureing
The Spectator I was knocked out by
Nicholas Shakespeare's book on in
Fleming um which is just a stupendous
work of research I mean he's you know
everybody has ever written a now
forgotten novel that has a minor
character in it he's faintly based on
some incident involing Fleming you know
he's read and tracked it down and he
basically discovers that in Fleming was
kind of more important than the man
wrote James Bond um and that yeah well
and it's just sort of really it's an
amazing scoop filled book about the
secret intelligence work that went on in
the second world war um at the center of
which it turns out Fleming w
yeah cuz I'd never really um realized
this before I mean I'm not a massive
Fleming or Bond fan but the sort of he
was involved in sort of quite mad
intelligence Capers himself wasn't he
Fleming is that right well he was I mean
he wasn't doing as much James Bond agent
in the field stuff as you might have
thought though there was a little bit of
that I mean he was sent off to kind of
retrieve the Belgian gold reserves and
smuggle them to safety from the Nazis at
one point um but he was I mean basically
the reason he didn't do much in the
field is because he knew too much and it
would be too dangerous to get him
captured he was really unlike other sort
of spy and intelligence aason writers
like lare or gram green who kind of gave
out that they were kind of quite
important in the Secret Service and
really w't Fleming was the real deal I
mean he he's sort of chaired very early
incarnations of the joint intelligence
committee he was privy to the sort of
top secret documents that only are very
small like a dozen or half a dozen
people would be able to lay eyes on and
he trained up this Commando group who
went raiding Europe after dday you know
basically trying to find Cutting Edge
German technological secrets so he was
he was really the real deal and that
that's a kind of extraordinary thing and
Nicholas
has you know
negotiated um all the silences in the
record because a lot of the stuff still
hasn't been Declassified and found you
know even found some old boy who'd
actually been in member of that Commando
unit and had met Fleming so he do all
sorts of extraordinary stuff it's a it's
absolutely gripping book and Nicholas
Shia being a really really good writer
it's it's beautifully written as well as
profoundly researched brilliant that
sounds like a fantastic recommendation
another book that struck me very
strongly um it was shortlisted for the
Samuel Johnson as was and bayy gford
prizes now is our major non-fiction
prize um didn't win in the end um was
Tanya br an's red memory I interviewed
her for our podcast um I think in the
summer and she's a China correspondent
who spent you know several years in
China reporting in China and it's it's
the fruit of her realization while she
was there that the cultural
revolution is something that's never
talked about in China but that is just
millimeters below the surface you know
that it completely informs the way China
is but it's a kind of repressed memory
um and it's about I it's not only about
what happened in the cultural revolution
but really about the way in which it has
been forgotten or suppressed or
romanticized in some cases or you know
co-opted in others and it's it's really
about
China's negotiation with its own past
and also about the fact that there's a
country that I mean she says of China
more or less what um the great Mas get
and said of Russia that it's a
essentially a country suffering
Collective
PTSD um so it's absolutely gripping book
it's extraordinarily well reported well
written and it just tells you a lot
about what you know quite how how
traumatic those events were and how
close they remain to you know just under
the surface of China's Consciousness
yeah I that's something i' not
appreciated enough actually is that how
close it was it of there'll be lots of
people that it's living memory for
example it's not just your abely
absolutely that and and some of them
weirdly because as you probably know the
cultural revolution basically involved a
complete inversion of all the
traditional confustion setup in China
where old older people were respected
and tradition was respected basically
got a bunch of teenage Hooligans and
encourag them to go around smashing
everything up and denouncing their
olders and their teachers and you know
their parents even with fatal
consequences I mean literally fatal
consequences and and yet a lot of the
veterans of this you know those those
teenagers who've now grown up um some of
them remember it kind of fondly because
a you know it was exciting and B they it
was kind of like this weird you know
think of those American Spring Break
movies only with murder you know they
were all sent off to to roam around the
countryside on on exciting
train you know special trains were laid
on and they'd go all over the place you
know basically having riots um but you
know they looked back on it with some
fondness it was they got to travel they
got to see places they hadn't seen and
they got to you know have teachers put
to death so you know very very very
weird you mentioned another spy novel as
well I believe one of the M oh well
there's another spy novel sorry I didn't
mind spy novels um well not s me Bond as
a spy novel was spy novels but the that
book was book about the biography of the
creator of bond um but I by now it's
become almost kind of boiler plate for
everybody who likes fins to greet a new
mck Heron with oh it's a new MC Haron
it's wonderful but you know mck Heron
really is bliss and the new one is
called um the secret hours I mean you
probably know mcaren stuff he's he's wro
written a series which is now on Apple
TV with Gary Oldman you know he's he's
gone from being a sort of Niche taste
that those in the know appreciate to
like super famous ER Lar sort of stuff
but he writes comic spy novels about
basically crap spies um who have been
kind of cashiered into the sort of dun's
Department of
MI5 but they always end up doing some
actual spying and it's always very
exciting and perilous um and they're
sort of
funny I mean really funny um but also
you know do the proper work of Thrillers
anyway um the new one the secret hours
is a is a it's a sort of prequel um
because the slow House series um which
he does is sort of contemporary and this
is one set in the bowels of the Cold War
um and involving Jackson lamb his kind
of fantastically charismatic and
unpleasant spy Master as a young man um
so it's in Berlin and it's all the all
the satisfactions of slow horses but you
know transposed to the the 60s early 60s
or late 50s do you um Sam do you think
the lare comparisons are fair and if any
viewers are big fans of lar do you think
they would would enjoy Heron's works I
think so I mean lar is kind of a sober
sides Heron is a comic novelist um as
much as he's a spy writer
and it's I mean I it's certainly kind of
takes some cues from lar not least
because slow house his um his sort of
home for home for spies who are in
disgrace is essentially you know it's a
kind of um funh house mirrror version of
L's circus um but the satisfactions of
lare in terms of plotting and action and
Intrigue are all there the writing is
beautiful and you and it's got jokes um
so I I think it's got everything a lcar
fan could hope for and a bit more he's
also it should be said he's not a
lcar imitator or copyist I mean he's
he's influenced by lend Dayton I'd have
thought as L car but again lend dayon
and carry neither of them jokes in quite
the same way so he's no he's the full
package he's a great thing M car oh very
good and tell us about your last book
only to make myself sound clever is um
Carlo rll's anaximander and the nature
of science which book came out right at
the beginning of the year and I was
lucky enough to have car relli in to
talk about it relli as probably our
viewers will know is
a um I mean he's a theoretical physicist
of quite some distinction he works on
something called luk quantum gravity
which I still haven't the faintest idea
what that is but he's also he's sort of
at the top of the range of that great
generation of you know hinky quantum
physics explainers um to those of us who
cannot do the extremely hard sums that
it involves um and so he's I mean he
kind of made his name with this thing
called seven brief left lessons in
physics which was a kind of collection
of short lectures which would just
explain to you you know some some aspect
of the absolutely wibbly wobbly world of
of quantum theory anaximander the new
book um or actually it's the last but
one book now because he's just done one
one of white holes um and aanda it was
thrilling to me because it's Rell
writing about someone who's one of his
Heroes I mean r is kind of a very
cultivated person you know he's got a
sort of hint land he's not just you know
straight down the line physicist um but
he's someone who you know he's
interested in poetry and literature and
culture and politics and how science
fits into that um and what an ax amander
is about is rll's hero who is this guy
who lived you know before the age even
of
Aristotle and was arguably the world's
first scientist and he was the first
person to um and his great Great Notion
was that the Earth rather than being
something that is completely flat and
sits underneath the sky he said that you
deduced that the Earth was a body
floating in space and that the Sun and
the Moon as they go kind of pass under
it around it rather than sort of
Vanishing at the end of the end of the
day and kind of reappearing magically at
the other end um and he made all sorts
of other um insights including the idea
that you know essentially he said there
were naturalistic explanations to things
so he made extraordinary guess at how
the water cycle works you know this
hundreds of years before the birth of
Christ um and he started to think about
how materials affected each other I mean
he it's basically he started trying to
find scientific or material causes for
things rather than mystical ones and his
method was a scientific method was the
idea of you know this paparian idea of
falsification and what relli does is is
talks a little about anaximander what we
know of him which is not all that much
um and how he Rel related to his
predecessors and teachers and how his
work comes down to us and you know what
he knew and what he didn't know but it's
not so much what at Nanda discovered
that rll is excited by it it's the way
he was thinking and the way he was
thinking was essentially completely new
um and relli then with great grace and
elegance as you'd expect from from a
writer of his caliber sort of talks
about how those discoveries and that way
of thinking resonate through subsequent
history and how the scientific method
you know why the scientific method
matters and the effects it's had on the
world we live in and it's just it's an
extraordinarily intellectually thrilling
book I have to say does he feel that
anim exander has the kind of same kind
of scientific method today or does he
feel like it's been distorted or does he
feel like it was a very sort of
primitive version of that do you think
well I think in the very broadest sense
he does I mean what he sort of says is
like it doesn't matter that an ax Amanda
thought you know the Earth was a
cylinder
um or that he you know got this and that
wrong he said it's not you know it's it
it's the way of thinking and the way of
thinking was one in which you sought
natural causes for things rather
than you know looking to gods or magic
to explain the phenomena of the world
around you um and that
anaximander took what his predecessor I
think was thees of myus I can't remember
off top of my head he said he took what
the
thought and he learned from it and he
then kind of modified it slightly said
you know this is all good but he got
this bit wrong and how about if he
thought and he said you know that's what
that's what science does you know it's
incremental it's Collective it involves
falsifying or modifying previous results
while at the same time learning from
them so in the very broadest sense I
think he claims an a amander as a
[Music]
mod